Sanders Thank You mr. chairman and thank
you for conducting a hearing on what I
suspect is the most serious problem
facing the people of the United States
and I think in my own state of Vermont
we have held a number of public hearings
in small towns on the health care crisis
that we have been amazed by the number
of people who have come out and who have
said the present system is no longer
working we need a major overhaul no more
tinkering we finally must go to a
national health care system which
guarantees health care every man woman
and child I'm sure that you are familiar
with the enormity of the problem the
system is disintegrating 35 million
Americans today have no health insurance
what happens to those people when
illness or accident strikes 50 million
people are underinsured can go bankrupt
as a result of a major illness we ranked
22nd in the world in terms of infant
mortality we ranked 12th in the world in
terms of life expectancy is that being
number one in the world I think not and
after all is said and done for a system
which is disintegrating we end up
spending far far more than any other
nation on earth the Canadians who are in
second place are spending thirty percent
less than we are clearly to my mind the
system cannot be tinkered with we need a
major overhaul we need to do with
virtually virtually every other nation
on earth has done and move toward a
national health care system the proposal
that we are bringing forth is in fact a
canadian-style system administrative Lee
and politically as I believe congressman
Russo or congressman Markey indicated
Canada did not move the national health
care full-blown in all of their
provinces it started in Saskatchewan my
own view and what this legislation
proposes is federal and legal authority
federal aid increased federal money and
legal authority for those states in the
country which are prepared to move
forward now with a single
a system which is comprehensive covers
all healthcare needs Universal covers
every man woman and child in the state
is portable allows that insurance to go
when people go out of their own state if
the state is prepared to do that they
will receive a block grant which brings
together Medicare Medicaid and
additional funding as others have
indicated it seems to me to be senseless
to move forward without eliminating the
private health insurance companies right
now while costing this country according
to the General Accounting Office 67
billion dollars in administrative and
bureaucratic waste we no longer can
afford all of the building access all of
the bureaucracy all of the legal fees
that presently exist positions for
national health care estimate that the
savings would be 100 billion dollars and
they're using more contemporary figures
the fact of the matter is that we can
provide health care comprehensive health
care of every man woman and child
without spending one penny more than the
750 billion dollars we're presently
spending if we take the money out of
paperwork out of bureaucracy and we use
that to provide health care are for our
people now this issue of health care to
my mind mr. chairman is not simply a
health-related issue this is an issue of
the political credibility of the United
States Congress it is not an accident
then in the last election sixty-five
percent of the american people did not
bother to vote for congress the question
that the people are asking is given the
enormous problem facing the people of
this country in health care and in other
areas is this Congress capable of
standing up to the insurance companies
to the drug companies to the medical
specialists of the medical equipment
suppliers the people who are making
billions and billions of dollars off of
a system that is disintegrating before
our eyes now the beauty of the system
that we are proposing is that
administrative ly it allows the states
to move forward and I believe as someone
who is a mayor for eight years that I
would rather see the single-payer system
rest
in the hands of the state legislature of
the people of the state rather than the
federal government which is precisely
what goes on in Canada also rather than
raising all of the money at the federal
level we give discretion the state
governments California may want to raise
our their share of the revenue different
our than the state of Vermont and we
think that's appropriate each state
should have that option so essentially
what our plan does is provide additional
financial help for those states who want
to go forward in single-payer
comprehensive universal care we give
those states the discretion of raising
their share in the best way that they
believe that they can do it so we think
that politically politically that is a
sensible approach for this body because
quite frankly although I've been only
here for six months I am not quite sure
that tomorrow or the United States
Congress is prepared to move forward in
terms of a shifting of the tax burden to
the tune of many many hundreds of
billions of dollars so we think
administrative Lee and politically
single-payer administered by the states
is the proper way to go we think it's
politically physical feasible we look
forward to your support thank you thank
you very much mr. Sanders and I'm
pleased that congressman Gibbons is with
us we were informed earlier he wasn't
going to be here we have your record
your statement already in the record but
we're delighted to have you here to make
a presentation to us we'd like to ask if
you would to limit the oral presentation
to no more than five minutes there's a
button on the base of the mic please
push it forward well thank you mr.
chairman I think you ought to know
historically how we got where we are
today and what I think is solution to
the problem 50 years ago today I went
off to war as a soldier in the United
States Army there was no health care
insurance the United States no health
insurance in the United States oh maybe
a couple of union contract had something
like that but there was really
relatively nothing during World War two
in order to keep that inflation wage and
price controls were imposed upon the
workers and businesses of this country
but imposing those
controls they left one door open and
that was fringe benefits and so during
World War Two a system of fringe
benefits in order to replace the dollars
that the workers weren't getting because
of inflation they built up this private
health care insurance system that we now
have it's a historic accident we have
let it grow on and it is a has brought
disaster to our whole health care system
we have not only the most expensive
health care system we have the most
clumsily administered system to work
with but we do have one system that
works in this country and one system for
which we already have the laws in place
we already have the administrators of
the bureaucracy in place we have all the
regulations written and the people who
use it like it that's Medicare so my
proposal to this Congress is that we
extend Medicare to all people regardless
of age regardless of their status in
life some of the characteristics at any
healthcare program for the United States
ought to have our first of all it should
be transportable it should not be job
dependent as I as our current system is
it should be open to all regardless of
their current health status or their
future health status and it should be
paid for by all it should be an
insurance program just like Medicare is
now now why use medicare medicare has 35
million participants already it has been
in existence for 26 years it works the
hospital's know how to use it the
doctors know how to use it the
beneficiaries know how to use it all the
health care suppliers know how to use it
and best of all we know or not best of
all but certainly on par with all of
that is that we know how to control
costs under Medicare unfortunately on
the current Medicare system we get the
most ill people of our
population and therefore the Medicare
cost of the medical care costs are
higher than there would be for the
entire working population if Medicare is
extended to all people as I propose then
the cost of medical care would be far
less in the United States then under the
current system and everybody would be
assured that whenever they got sick or
if they needed preventive health care or
advice our counseling they could go to a
doctor or to their provider and get that
kind of health care it is not a radical
program it is not a new program there
would still be some area in there for
the private insurance industry if they
wanted to sell Medigap insurance but if
you take care of those optional
procedures that some people desire or
say a private room or something of that
sort over a over a semi-private room is
we now offer in Medicare so there are
all these kinds of things that make it
attractive to America it is an American
program it is a proven program it is one
that will save money to the average
consumer and taxpayer it is one that
will promote better health for all
Americans unfortunately most of the
Americans who are now not covered by
health insurance are children who really
can do nothing about it and they're most
of them are in families where the father
and the mother are both working or at
least one of them is working in a job
outside of the home so we have a very
vulnerable group of people in America
that are not covered it is estimated
that in a year's time mr. chairman that
about 60 million people are not covered
by any kind of health care insurance in
the United States not just 35 million as
we see in those snapshots of one time
during the year so we've got a terrible
meet in this country we can solve it by
extending Medicare to all we should do
it at once
thank you very much mr. Gibbons mr.
Gibbons and mr. Russo your programs are
federally run programs and miss O'Connor
Mr Sanders as I understand it your
programs are federal dollars to go to
the state to run the health care system
and missile car as I understand your
proposal you would cover not only the
acute care costs but the long-term care
costs as would mr. Russo but Mr Sanders
and and the mr. Gibbins do not cover the
lawn care of course our plan would cover
all it's a comprehensive plan as I
indicated covering all health care needs
it would cover nursing homes and just as
the Canadian system does it would cover
all basic health canada i didn't long
term care they you you proposed to send
to the states a certain amount of money
there would be the equivalent of what
Medicaid Medicare plus if all 50 states
entered tomorrow which is highly
unlikely there would be a 45 billion
dollar increase in federal help for
healthcare to the states what our
proposal does is eliminate the private
insurance premiums that we pay
out-of-pocket costs give the states the
savings that a single-payer system would
entail in my small state of Vermont we
estimate that to be two hundred million
dollars and then the state itself
through its own tax system picks up the
rest does your bill proposed to have the
federal government capture the amount of
money that would have been spent through
the private insurance market through
employers employees and then after the
federal government captures that money
to send it to the States our proposal
allows the state's the savings that
would be entailed in a single-payer
system the states would capture that the
federal government would raise 45
billion dollars i'm at the savings the
savings the argument would go is that
you'd spend less money if you had a
single payer right but there's most
dollars that are spend in the health
care area our dollars that are spent
without the government being involved
right now those are employers cover
their employees the employers and
employees private insurance and so forth
you're going to have this replace by a
government run at the state level the
health insurance the money then to fund
it would that be raised
by the federal government including the
amount that otherwise would have been
spin states will raise the people in the
state would no longer have to pay all of
these private insurance the state would
pick up the tab for that in a way that
they felt was best for each individual
state I see so the states would then
seek to raise the funds knowing that
businesses in that state are not
spending their money they had spent
before well we would that's right but we
would give discretion obviously we
expect and would believe in my state of
Vermont that we'd raise it as
progressively as we could it would mean
that IBM would not have to pay private
insurance they would in all likelihood
have to pay a higher corporate income
tax individuals might have to pay what
protection do you have from the idea
that states would be pitted against each
other by businesses who were threatened
to move if they raise taxes and to try
to fund more generous health insurance
but we think actually it might almost be
the other way about in in the sense that
it it makes good sense for business if
in fact they know that they don't have
to pay twenty or thirty percent more
every year for private insurance which
is often the case in my state and around
the country so in fact as you know one
of the concerns that business in the
United States today has in terms of its
competitiveness abroad is they are
competing against countries which have
national health care so we think that
the approach of national health care is
really very sensible for business and
those states that go forward will gain
from that cost containment would be
different from state to state know what
we are doing is while we're giving
discretion to the states in terms of how
you would raise your revenue in the same
sense the Canada does some go for income
tax on go for sales tax and so forth and
so on my preference is progressive
taxation or what we do say is that if a
state comes into the program you know it
must be single-payer comprehensive
universal portable accessible to all we
don't grant discretion on that we are
not saying to once they hey you can do
it any way you want notice that you can
do it any way you want we are giving
discretion how you raise the funds
certain administrative issues but
basically it is comprehensive and
universal